[Laughter]
[Applause]
you dare enter this house on a Monday
morning [ __ ] get ready
that's how we do it [ __ ] Monday
July 30 it another month goes down but
you get [ __ ] stronger you understand
me August is here all these [ __ ]
Momo's around going on vacation jumping
up and down you you got your [ __ ]
eyeballs on focus [ __ ] it's uncle Joey
[ __ ] it's Monday it's a
beautiful day to be alive [ __ ] the
sun's out the birds are chirping not to
mention the warmth from the [ __ ] nut
sack juice is running through your
[ __ ] body ready to stab a
[ __ ] in the neck understand me I
want to congratulate John Jones my main
man house I want to congratulate [ __ ]
Daniel Cormier he's a [ __ ] savage of
debt but this is a whole new [ __ ]
week ladies and gentlemen and it's all
up to you what you're gonna do the
mission for the week is you're gonna be
a little better than what you wore last
week you don't give a [ __ ] what happened
last week last week was last week you
wash your balls
you [ __ ] powdered your [ __ ]
nutsack you [ __ ] wash your little
monkey ladies and now you're out there
who gives a [ __ ] this is your week
[ __ ] today's your lucky day
but listen we're smoking some [ __ ]
sweet tooth from Arkham perennial today
I'm headed over there to head 10:01 to
get my sack for the week
I like the one I drew showing up at two
o'clock at a jujitsu today I got a
podcast up we got everything today it's
a non-stop type of [ __ ] day and I
suggest you have the same cuz even when
you're not busy you should be busy
generous that's what people are no I'm
not busy three always busy there's
always something you could do write a
letter [ __ ] send the [ __ ] email or
something there's always something you
could do don't shoot them look at me and
tell me I ain't got dick to do you got
plenty to do [ __ ] okay and you
start with smoking a bowl writing your
goals or vacuuming for your [ __ ] wife
maybe do a few dishes and then get out
of the house and figure out how you
gonna put an envelope in your [ __ ]
pocket today if you want to settle for
[ __ ] less small and below you don't
have a small envelope if you want a
medium one you can have a medium if you
have a big one you should have a big one
or if you want a big black dick up your
ass you have one of those it's up to you
you're the captain grip to your [ __ ]
future you control your fate don't look
at me like your life has been bad to me
life was bad to me too
I had to get a gun in a knife and do
what I had to do to put it together 227
[ __ ] years but wait here got
something and I suggest you do the same
rome wasn't built in a [ __ ] day you
[ __ ] do something for four days
and all sudden you're like it's not
working no it's not working you have to
do the same [ __ ] thing every [ __ ]
day if you want it to work with your
nose in there you gotta put that nose in
the [ __ ] [ __ ] bang it you gotta
get in there get your hands dirty
what do you think they giving out in
barbers out there because you're special
because you got a tattoo of a [ __ ]
bird or some [ __ ] get your [ __ ] together
it's Monday [ __ ] half the year went by
you still sitting there I'm still
smoking with will be sure that did your
[ __ ] life together you miserable
[ __ ] anyway I'm sorry any little motion
on Mondays I want you [ __ ] to
go out and conquer your demons you know
who your biggest demon is that you you
dumb [ __ ] that's what biggest always got
demons what [ __ ] demon you're the
[ __ ] demon when I was snorting coke
and [ __ ] mother breaking into houses
we think somebody else is a demon how
was the [ __ ] demon I don't have no
demons in my closet mumbo I got a couple
skeletons of the sitting in there and I
checked them from time to time that's
why you don't lose your [ __ ] mind
check on them and make sure they're all
right give him a little [ __ ] grow up
some what's that [ __ ] you put on people
when you kill him and then you bury him
lie you gotta rub some lye on those
bones you know exactly anyway it's a
beautiful day to be alive all right sure
when it comes to Mondays I get emotional
you know why cuz it starts Monday this
is one it's nice nice I've been up since
5:00 [ __ ] 30 jumping up and down
right and sending emails I got everybody
had a [ __ ] attention to it I got
everybody other attention you understand
me that's what I want you to do with
your [ __ ] life listen every day
you're a little better than what you
were yesterday
you're a little smarter you're a little
wiser if the IRS calls you tell you
they're coming over to take you to jail
time the [ __ ] go [ __ ] themselves the
same [ __ ] queue but nobody can just
pick you up and take you to jail you
dumb [ __ ] and stop standing on
line for food you dumb [ __ ] you
[ __ ] are ruining for real
savages like us we don't stand on line
for [ __ ] eggs and for breakfast I
just went to a place got 20 people out
there waiting for [ __ ] it what is
wrong with you
but the [ __ ] is wrong with you Gentiles
do you really want no wonder you want
you you want to be [ __ ] Russian you
want to wait on line look at us waiting
on line for barbecue in Austin what the
book is wrong with you people listen
people from the church we don't stand on
line you understand we don't do that
[ __ ] for [ __ ] two eggs what the [ __ ]
is wrong with and you wonder why Isis is
sneaking and every [ __ ] day because
you're busy [ __ ] way between
30-minute wait I will wait how can we
not eat easier get the [ __ ] out here you
take a [ __ ] hot pan you throw two
ways on that [ __ ] it's just with
that stupid [ __ ] restaurants book but
anyway come see come sir here's the
schedule for the week
we got a podcast tonight we got a
podcast Wednesday night Tuesday night
I'm at the [ __ ] store and
Saturday night I'm doing a special
working out with Joey Diaz at the ice
off 7:30 you wrap that 9 15 bucks you
gonna get that type entertainment I
write my [ __ ] out for the week and we
bring it up onstage Saturday night I got
that on the fifth or the 19th I'm in
training you guys want me to go to next
level I'm trying to take it to the
[ __ ] next level nobody get you to the
next level you get yourself to the next
level so strap your boss powder your
[ __ ] nut sack write your [ __ ]
goals comb your hair brush it keep a
little Listerine you know I smell my
breath this morning I smell like I
[ __ ] like 22 the real [ __ ]
there's some Listerine and get out there
and spread your love and your wisdom
it's that simple of magnimous in your
house like a [ __ ] bunch and watch
commercials 5tp pack or whatever the
[ __ ] they put on the date their smug
little the bully you guys got me all
fired up Lakers pilot to Bombardier
pilot to Bombardier uncle Joey swinging
dick and giving our bubblegum a few
[ __ ] don't understand what I'm
saying oh yeah I didn't get my metal
I'll ping the holy book Italy oh you
your sleigh commander your soy Capri
tongue the book I said it
oh yeah that didn't get my metal up in
the hole sorry you see no in the oily
mayhem i said in Aoyama don't call this
house no more if you're not gonna walk
then get your dick sucked up with
[ __ ] nine hands you understand me
that's it and that's that
I love you [ __ ] put on my heart
you know this without you I got nothing
right you don't see me hangin what are
you I got nothing all right cut this
[ __ ] uncle Joey full effect tonight I
don't know what time the podcasts gonna
start pay attention I'll get back to you
[ __ ] or their hero called me up
my book it'll be cool just like you
didn't come on my boy I love your
[ __ ] stay black Saturday night
the Ice House $15 working out with uncle
Joey don't forget about me